big cat I assume two things about you
today one you're sleep-deprived and two
you are very happy because as we
established on the two minutes stub on
the TV side on the way in the Bears are
back the Bears are back and I am very
sleep-deprived that was a game that I'm
still buzzing off of it was one of those
games that you get home I got home
around 1:30 in the morning and I said I
need to read all everything that I can
read about the game about the postgame
press conference just kind of bask in
the glow so working at about three hours
of sleep but the Bears were back and
that's all that matters and Mike they
played a legitimately great football
game last night I know people are gonna
say the Cowboys stink they said the
Lions think and that may be true but is
you know very well you've been covering
this league for a very long time it's
hard to win and it's hard to put
together a complete football game like
the Bears did last night and mr. Biscay
should we say it Mike
I have a stat for you do you want me to
go with the stat right off the bat or
you want me to look tonight I'll wing it
on me land on me land on me blast it by
the way this comes from the Twitter
account stats by stats I can't believe
stats didn't get this Twitter account
but last night
mr. Biscay completed 70 Plus percent of
his passes on 30 plus attempts he threw
three touchdown passes he rushed for
50-plus yards and he had a rushing
touchdown all in the same game the first
quarterback to ever do that in the NFL
Mike well I'd like to know how that one
was verified but it sounds good so let's
go with it I have a question for you
about your process about your postgame
enjoyment of the big win do you only
focus on the comments and the reports
and the columns that focus on the Bears
or do you allow yourself to enjoy the
misery of the team they vanquished and
see what guys like Jerry Jones and Jason
Garrett had to say it completely depends
last night the Cowboys were absolutely
irrelevant to me I did not care I feel
like we're doing the same exact thing
every single week with the Cowboys where
they lose
disappointing game and then Jerry Jones
stands in a hallway and you know subtly
implies that Jason Garrett might not be
the coach next year then kind of walks
it back on Tuesday when he does his
radio hit so the Cowboys were irrelevant
to me in terms of overall though as a
fan if it's a rivalry game if it's a
team I hate I will be watching all of
the losing teams press conferences
actually a good good point to throw out
there the badgers wisconsin badgers
where i went to school they played the
Minnesota Golden Gophers last Saturday I
watched 15 minutes of a Facebook live of
PJ Fleck talking about how they won the
division so yes I do I do basking in the
losers when it's a rivalry when it's a
game I really feel like passionate about
this one I can get to the Cowboys later
what do you think has gone right for the
Bears in recent weeks one of the big
criticisms of Chicago earlier this year
they didn't have a true offensive
identity that's something Sims was all
over from week one when we saw them
sluggishly lose to the Green Bay Packers
with what do you think clicked and how
do they keep that going so more than
anything I think it's just confidence in
mr. Biscay and that Lions game that last
Drive that winning drive and everyone
will say it's the Lions and yes the
Lions are very very bad but that drive
at the end of the game to go 80 yards 80
plus yards to make throws deep to get
that touchdown when they're down a field
goal and you might say oh they're gonna
sell for a field we'll try to win in the
overtime that drive right there I think
something clicked with mr. Biscay and
when he has confidence when he has his
teammates rallying around him you know
watch that game last night the the body
language of his teammates the exuberance
on the sidelines was such a stark
difference in the beginning of this year
and when he has that confidence and he's
making quick decisions and more than
anything Mike you saw it last night he
had I think it was a play in the first
quarter where he clearly had a first
down run and he was still trying to pass
then finally he's like you know what I'm
just gonna run for this when he can use
his feet he's a different
because it alleviates a lot of the
pressure when it comes to making
decisions when getting to the third read
on the on offense he can say you know
what I'm a Tucket and ronnie has that
athleticism
so it's Mitch's confidence is number one
and the Bears all season long if you've
watched this team closely you know that
complimentary football has been a big
problem because the defense at times
while still a very very good defense has
had moments where it looks like they
don't really want to be out there
because they know their offense can't
help them the Philadelphia Eagles game
is a perfect example where the Bears had
nine total yards in the first half on
offense and the defense looked like hey
we don't want to be doing this why are
we doing this if we can't even get a
single yard throwing the ball then
second half they come out and the
offense clicks a little and the defense
steps up and I think you saw that last
night I think when you see mr. Biscay
coming back from that first interception
and being able to move the ball still
the defense ramps up with the offense
and Matt naggy play calling he's neat
deserves credit he's running the ball
very well there they have a complete
game set and lastly Mike the tight end
position the tight end position has been
a big Bugaboo for Ryan pace Trey Burton
has been pretty much a zero when it
comes to free agent signings and that
happens you know you can't really do
anything he's drafted a couple guys that
haven't really panned out and last night
you see guys who are unheralded guys
step up in the tight end position and
the offense looks a lot different when
mitch has a guy he can throw to in the
tight end position so I'll put that all
together and I'm obviously a little
tongue-in-cheek when I say bears are
back because I know it's an uphill
battle I know they have to win out and
need help but this is positive things
with Chicago Bears in a season that
looked completely lost a month ago and
they have to win out against the Packers
the Chiefs and the Vikings and you know
every year there's a team that is
hovering around 500 right around
Thanksgiving that finds the gas pedal
that floors it that has that path that
eventually emerges and they get to the
playoffs and they're very dangerous when
they get there because they've already
been playing playoff games
each and every week leading up to the
wild-card round so I think actually if
the Bears find a way into this they'll
be better suited to win in January when
they then they were last year when you
go into it with everything to lose now
you got nothing to lose if you make it
cuz you weren't supposed to be there in
the first place and let me go back to
your point about the confidence that
true Biscay earned for himself
and through his teammates with the drive
at the end of the game against the Lions
because when he throws that interception
on the first drive of the night for the
Bears after the defense gave up a 17
play 75 yard touchdown drive you know if
they don't have confidence in true
Biscay it's not a quick three and out
and you get a short field and then
you're able to get the touchdown and tie
the game up 7 to 7 and that's the kind
of thing that could turn the game
haywire
you know if the Bears defense allows the
Cowboys to embark on another long drive
there and it's 10 to nothing or 14 to
nothing it's an entirely different game
so how the defense responded when
Mitchell drew Biscay threw an
interception to end the first drive I
think that had a lot to do with laying
the foundation for the victory and one
of the reasons they stepped up very well
may have been that they believe more in
Mitch now than they did five or six
weeks ago yeah that's absolutely true
and Mike you can tell me because you've
been covering football for a lot longer
than I have but can you remember a
player that has been more maligned
publicly that mr. Biscay and I'll put my
hand up because I've said many times
that I you know I've had a serious
doubts and I've had serious anger when
it comes to how the season has gone and
how this franchise seems to not be able
to put together consecutive quality
seasons just ever but have you could you
remember a guy who gets the type of like
ridicule that mr. Biscay has so I think
he becomes somewhat of a sympathetic
figure in that locker room and guys
really want to root for him and I said
this after the Lions game I'll say it
again that today I'm genuinely happy for
mr. risky whether the Bears make the
playoffs or not these moments I'm
genuinely happy for him because most
guys would not be able to come back from
how bad
it's looked at times and also how much
they have been kind of dragged and
rightfully so sometimes by the by the
media by Twitter whatever it may be
Michell risky has been in a very bad
spot when it comes to where he was
drafted in the guys that were drafted
behind him I mean that's it it's it's a
perfect storm of factors that have
conspired against the Bears and matura
Biscay where the criticism comes from
inside from outside from fans of the
team to fans of the rivals and the
division and fans of any team it just
becomes kind of a laughingstock
situation and true Biscay had to find
himself in the middle of it and I think
part of it too was Matt Negi wasn't
handling in the right way you know those
moments that we saw earlier this year
where naggy seemed exasperated with him
and and yelling at him and and you know
just it seems like it was ten years ago
the mysterious hip injury against the
the Rams
I feel like Nagy figured out how to
properly deal with Mitch true Biscay to
push his buttons the right way to allow
that confidence to come out again
because I think the head coach had a lot
to do with why true Biscay was afraid of
his own shadow
yeah no you're absolutely right that
moment the the phantom hip injury out in
LA does seem like it was a pivotal
moment in this season for the Bears
because they've gone on to win the next
three games now again not great
opponents but you play what your
schedule says it is you know you can't
really change that but you're right Matt
Nagy has had moments where he has looked
like the job has been too big for him
and the way he's dealt with the press he
looks like the job is too big for him
something has happened something has
changed
he's been preaching silver linings
that's what he's been saying in all his
press conferences he's been saying it to
the team we have a silver lining
somewhere we don't know when it's going
to come through but there will be a
silver lining to this season and right
now he looks like keeping his team
together
he needs to be commended for it and I'm
here to do it because I'll tell you when
it when I think you're doing a bad job
and I'll tell you when I think you're
doing a great job and right now Matt
Nagy's doing a great job and there have
been times this season where he's been
doing you know he's had a rough job and
here's the positive even if the Bears
don't make it to the playoffs it creates
we've seen over the past few weeks a
plausible sense of hope for 2020 whereas
five six weeks ago where is the hope
where is the reason to think that
anything is going to be remotely
productive and competitive in 2020 and I
think that's a big part of it too
absolutely Mike because knowing how the
NFL is structured knowing how the first
round pick contracts are structured the
Bears are gonna be in a tight spot
because you have to decide before May
about mr. whiskies fifth year option and
I don't think there is any there's
really no scenario and you can tell me
if I'm wrong here where you can spend
that draft capital on a quarterback and
not at least try to give them that fifth
year so they were gonna pick it up no
matter what
like whether Mitch played well - down
the stretch I think they're gonna pick
it up hope he played well in his fourth
year and then you have them for your
fifth year and it's you know guaranteed
against injury but the Bears didn't have
a lot of moves coming up this offseason
they don't have a first-round draft pick
they have two seconds and no third so
you know there's a lot of guys that are
getting a lot of money and in the cap
situation and mr. Biscay so this was one
of those spots where the Bears were not
gonna have a lot of wiggle room when it
comes to drastically changing this team
before next year so having this positive
momentum and having these wins is so
huge if you want to win in 2020 knowing
there won't be a lot of changes on the
roster and there won't be a lot of
changes when it comes to the coaching
staff
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports